south africa has deployed its military
to stop violence sparked by the jailing
of former president jacob zuma
at least six people have died hundreds
more have been arrested
south africa's highest court has begun
hearing zuma's appeal against his
15-month prison sentence for contempt
president siobha ramaphosa has called
for calm
warning the unrest could lead to
shortages of food and medicine
soldiers guard the streets of south
africa they're there to protect police
after protests marked by looting and
destruction of property
became more violent loot has plundered a
large shopping mall in durban overnight
it's one of many businesses in the port
city that were ransacked over the
weekend
another shopping mall lies in ruins in
peter martinsburg
some 80 kilometers from durban
the unrest has been mainly concentrated
in the southeastern province of
kwazulu-natal
zuma's home region many of his
supporters there are angered by zuma's
15-month jail term
imposed for failing to appear at a
corruption inquiry
but now the violence has also spread to
johannesburg
south africa's economic powerhouse with
police stretch thin
the army will deploy troops to the two
most affected regions
although these may be opportunistic acts
of
looting driven by hardship and poverty
the poor and the marginalized bear the
ultimate brunt of the destruction that
is
currently underway zuma is popular among
many of south africa's less well-off
his imprisonment has laid bare deep
divisions in the country